President Joe Biden has proposed raising
the corporate income tax rate
from 21% to 28%. The rate increase would raise more than
$700 billion in additional
revenue over the next decade
to help finance his American Jobs Plan.
A higher corporate tax rate will help
finance new spending, but it will come at a cost.
A higher corporate rate increases the incentive
to shift profits out of the United States.
Under Biden's proposal, the US corporate tax rate,
including state and local taxes, would be roughly 32%
and the highest among OECD nations. This
will make it more attractive to locate
income in foreign jurisdictions.
A higher corporate tax rate would also
make investing in the United States
more expensive. A higher tax burden
on investment can lead to a smaller capital stock,
lower labor productivity, and lower
economic output in the long run.
To the extent that a corporate tax rate
reduces labor productivity,
it will lead to lower wages for everyday workers.
How high do you think the corporate tax
rate should be?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.